deutsche panzer für die ukraine diese
panzer hier hinter uns typ gepard das
ist nicht das was die ukraine bestellt
hat aber eben doch es sind panzer und
seit 24 stunden spricht ganz deutschland
über diese gepaart panzer was sind das
für dinger was können die wie können die
im ukraine krieg helfen bild geht jetzt
auf diesen panzer fährt jetzt mit mit
einem solchen gepard panzer peter wilke
wir schalten live zu unserem bild
reporter und dem panzer peter
patricia wir sind hier im militär
technikmuseum in uffenheim in bayern und
können uns heute ebenso ein gepard ein
älteres modell anschauen das in den
anfang der 2000 jahre ausgemustert wurde
aber eigentlich zumindestens von außen
genauso aussieht wie auch die modelle
die in die ukraine geliefert werden wir
können uns das einmal hier von außen
anschauen wie der aussieht es ist eben
dieser luftabwehr panzer der vor allen
dingen eben wie der name schon sagt
dafür da ist um luft zu beschiessen aber
auch er ziele beschließen kann sie sehen
es knapp 50 tonnen schwer also wirklich
ein massives teil ja und jetzt bei uns
ist michael bucher der selber zwölf
jahre lang in der bundeswehr gedient hat
und genau auf diesen panzer gearbeitet
hat bei der luftabwehr michael kannst du
uns einmal erklären was genau kann
dieser panzer wo könnte der in der
ukraine eingesetzt viele schon gesagt
hat es ist ein älteres modell also hier
haben noch die version 1.1 die ukraine
bekommen die version 12 die ist
natürlich anfang der 2000er
komplett gesteigert worden hat einen
neuen digitalen rechner bekommen neue
pool keilereien eine klimaanlage
eingerüstet die ist natürlich
äußerlich ist sie diesem modell hier
sehr ähnlich aber technisch auf einem
ganz anderen stand ja kann tief und tief
fliegende luftfahrzeuge bekämpfen klein
luftfahrzeuge wie drohnen oder kleins
flugzeuge und natürlich auch ist dagegen
eher ziele sehr sehr wirksam und
die ist wo der viel darüber diskutiert
dass deutsche panzer zuerst gar nicht
geliefert werden konnten weil man so
lange daran ausgebildet werden muss weil
die ukrainische kräfte die nicht
bedienen könnten was so ist so schwer
daran zu bedienen ist der schwer zu
bedienen im vergleich zu anderen panzern
und wie lange muss man an dem
ausgebildet werden nun es ist natürlich
ein sehr komplexes waffensystem die
bedienung soll das schon die baugruppen
und die die bauteile wie es die die
energieversorgungsanlagen die
hydraulische anlage die waffen sollte
die bedienung bedienen können auch im
einsatz und allein das zu auszubilden
intensiv auszubilden dauert einige
wochen alles klar dann lasst uns das
ding vielleicht gleich mal anschmeißen
ich gehe oben drauf du dort vorne in die
fahrerkabine und dann können wir mal ein
ründchen hier fahren
was muss man denn hier besonders
beachten wenn man einsteigt davon
irgendwelche teile nicht treffen muss
man vorsichtig sein also am besten oben
nur auf die gelben trittflächen treten
das heißt auf dieses oberteile und auf
die auf die bretter das ist alles geld
markiert da kann man drauf treten
ansonsten kann man da nicht viel kaputt
machen ist ein panzer danke ja und
michael hatte uns auch im vorgespräch
schon gesagt dass man wir haben ihn bei
der bundeswehr drei monate an diesen
panzer trainiert das kann man aber
tatsächlich eben wie er gesagt hat auf
einige wochen reduzieren da einige
formalien im kriegsfall wie jetzt in der
ukraine wegfallen können wir sehen hier
hier wird die munition hinein geladen
die dann eben verschossen wird ich gehe
jetzt mal oben rein
dort wo dann die soldaten sitzen würden
passt ein bisschen auf michael du kannst
gerne schon mal an machen
ja und jetzt ziehen die partie ab werk
panzer ein hindernis modell wie das das
in die ukraine geliefert werden soll
jetzt ja dass der beschluss der
bundesregierung grünes licht für die
lieferung solcher gepard kampfpanzer in
die ukraine unser reporter bild reporter
peter wilke dort gerade oben auf einem
solchen panzer es immer wieder in den
vergangenen wochen vor allen dingen aus
der regierung von der spd seit es sei
wahnsinnig kompliziert solche dinger
dann auch zu fahren zu bedienen das
wollen wir uns in diesen minuten in
diesen stunden einmal ganz genau
anschauen und eben beschreiben lassen
von peter wege den sie dort oben sehen
peter übernimmt nochmal und versuchen
sein blick dort rein zu können diesen
gepard kampfpanzer
[Musik]
ja also kann es sei eben schwierig für
uns das jetzt mit der kamera zu zeigen
ist alles sehr eng hier oben so wie ich
das hier sehen kann wir haben es
beschrieben relativ alte technik das ist
bei den neuen modellen jetzt in die
ukraine geliefert werden wohl anders das
ist alles sehr viel mehr digitalisiert
aber von der bauart her vom können her
ist dieser panzer eben ziemlich der
gleiche der der jetzt in die ukraine
geht und ja wir haben darüber gesprochen
hier kommt die munition rein das ist
eben genau die munition von der es wohl
dann doch zu wenig gibt also die ukraine
trägt jetzt die panzer aber die munition
die dafür benötigt wird die gibt es in
deutschland gar nichts
lasst uns vielleicht noch mal eine runde
drehen
und
kannst du uns vielleicht noch einmal
beschreiben du hast selber zwölf jahre
lang auf diesen panzer gedient mit dem
panzer gearbeitet du hast erzählt er
hätte dann da auch trainiert mit wie
trainiert man mit so einem panzer worauf
wird dort geschossen naja also zunächst
mal gab es natürlich auch damals gibt
auch heute zum teil noch simulator
technik ja das heißt man hat die panzer
an simulatoren angeschlossen oder es gab
eigenständige simulatoren die eben für
die touren besatzung waren oder gleich
für eine ganze batterie also eine ganze
einheit
später dann bei dem einsatz wo gab es
dann nur noch so turm simulatoren da
natürlich hauptsächlich darauf trainiert
weil ich ständig rausfahren ins gelände
kostet halt ziemlich viel sprit
natürlich ist man auch ab und zu auf
übungen gefahren
wie viel sprit verbraucht er so
naja so circa 500 liter auf 100
kilometer ihr hättet uns auch erzählt
dass es ein sehr kostspieliges also ihr
sammelt die hier in dem museum das ist
sehr kostspielig die teile für diesen
panzer sind sehr teuer kannst du uns
dann erklären was muss man da unter
anderem auf dem tisch lägen für so
manche ersatzteile
naja über preise wie nie so informiert
weil ich diese dann nur ein aber
man bekommt schon dass eine andere auf
ebay aber es geht ja schon teilweise um
mehrere tausend euro das kann natürlich
auch dahin gehen ja ja dann lasst uns
vielleicht noch mal weiterfahren mit den
panzern und bei runden drehen so weil es
unter juristen bei aus altenheimen aus
dem lasst uns ein bisschen was über die
geschütze noch erfahren dort also lasst
uns einmal dort einerseits auf das radar
schauen und dann aber auch in ja dieses
gewaltige hohe also wie weit reichen die
geschütze dort was kann dieser gepard
kampfpanzern
genau das hat uns michael vorhin schon
erklärt dass der kampfpanzer hat eben
ein radar hier vorne und der radar
scannt dann sozusagen den luftraum ab
die flugobjekte die dort lang pflegen
dann unter anderem in der ukraine und
misst immer die winkel die diese luft
überdies diese flugobjekte zum panzer
haben und entsprechend was dieses radar
misst werden dann die geschosse aus
diesen beiden waren auf beiden ohren
kommen dann jeweils die geschosse werden
in richtung der flugzeuge ein bisschen
davor sozusagen geschossen damit es wird
sozusagen einen punkt in den himmel
gesetzt wird und das mit uns michael
erklärt und in diesem punkt fliegt das
flugobjekt an rhein und wird so daneben
getroffen das soll dieser panzer eben
dann in der ukraine leisten um eben den
ukrainischen luftraum zu beschützen was
ja auch oft beschrieben wurde von vor
ort das ist ein großes problem ist dass
die ukraine keine kontrolle die trainer
keine kontrolle über ihren luftraum
haben dass sie vor allen dingen mit
luftangriffen kämpfen müssen und das
soll wohl eben dieser gepard panzer in
der ukraine lösen aber das große problem
ist eben noch die munition die hier
vorne herein kommt auf beiden seiten von
der es eben nicht genug aktuell gibt in
deutschland die nicht in ausreichenden
mengen mitgeliefert werden kann
interpretiert uns mal zeigen was man an
diesen panzer noch alles bewegen kann
also dass von dem radar gesprochen man
muss ja dann auch das rohr richtung
himmel aus fahren wenn es um die
flugabwehr geht vielleicht könnt ihr uns
mal ein bisschen zeigen was man in
welche richtung in diesem panzer wie
agil er sich verhalten kann
genau also michael
einmal noch mal zu ihm er hat uns nun
erklärt der panzer könnte
aussteigen und wo sich sein hat uns
führen erklärt können sich eben hier
oben drehen der tour mit diesem objekt
allerdings muss der panzer dafür erst
ein bisschen warm laufen 30 minuten
insgesamt das würde jetzt wahrscheinlich
übersteigen aber michael vielleicht
kannst du uns noch einmal erklären wie
agil ist dieser panzer wie schnell kann
der fan wie lange reicht eine ladung wie
gut ist er eben geeignet fürs gelände
auch im vergleich zu anderen pflanzen
naja es ist halt das leopard eins vorweg
was natürlich nicht unbedingt die psd
hatte das leopard 2 vorweg wir haben ja
nur 830 ps wobei auch das ausreichend
ist wir können auf der straße circa 65
stundenkilometer schnell fahren wir
können im gelände
ja zwischen 25 und 30 je nach gelände
fahren ja
also es gibt nicht viele hindernisse
dieses fahrzeug aufhalten können krank
reden überschreiten bis zu einem meter
das ist alles kein problem für das
fahrzeug wenn wir uns richtig bedienen
kann ja wir haben gehört von michael
soweit also der panzer ist durchaus agil
und gelände fähig und ja mit bis zu 75
65 km h auch relativ schnell im gelände
ist das dann natürlich etwas langsamer
und er so weit von hier aus uffenheim
aus dem panzer museum wir konnten uns
jetzt ganz genau das modell anschauen
was eben dort in die ukraine geliefert
wird danke für den moment dank an
unseren bild reporter peter wilke dort
auf diesem gepard kampfpanzer einem
solchen modell wie sie jetzt ganz
ähnlich eben in die ukraine geliefert
werden sollen deutsche panzer für die
ukraine das wollten wir uns direkt dort
anschauen heute und wir wollen weiter
sprechen mit patrick sensburg dem chef
des reservistenverbandes der deutschen
bundeswehr auch über diesen neuen
beschluss der bundesregierung herzlich
willkommen herr salzburg ich grüße sie
also wir haben uns gerade diesen
eindruck verschafft direkt vor ort von
einem solchen gepard paar kampfpanzer
die überzeugt sind sie davon dass das
dass diese lieferung der ukraine
wirklich hilft also erst mal sieht man
ganz deutlich dass es ein gutes
waffensystem ist es ein modernes
waffensystem das zeigt zwei sachen
einmal dass die ukraine den gepard
braucht es ist ein flugabwehr panzer die
ukraine kämpft gerade damit dass die
russischen truppen die lufthoheit haben
der gepard kann dabei helfen die eigenen
truppen am boden zu sichern gegen
luftangriffe dementsprechend zu schützen
es zeigt aber auch dass wir vielleicht
in deutschland dieses gute moderne
waffensysteme zu ausgemustert haben
dieses waffensystem zu früh ausgemustert
und gleichzeitig werden stimmen laut
wonach die ukraine ja eine liste
abgegeben hat und da war jetzt dieser
panzer nicht unbedingt am ersten zwei
oder vielleicht dritte platz also es
wurden ganz andere waffen gefordert
welche waffen braucht die ukraine
derzeit am dringendsten und für wie
wahrscheinlich halten sie es dass sie
diese waffen dann auch von deutscher
seite bekommen ich glaube die ukraine
braucht zurzeit vieles sie braucht
natürlich zur bekämpfung von panzern
panzerabwehrwaffen sie braucht natürlich
munition für alles das was sie benötigt
da gilt dann natürlich jetzt auch der
gepard darunter das auch für den gepard
die munition gefunden werden muss das
ist nicht ganz so einfach weil die
position zumindest das pulver in der
munition in der schweiz hergestellt wird
da haben wir derzeit lieferprobleme aber
es gibt auch andere länder die das
gps-system derzeit noch nutzen munition
haben mit denen muss man reden auch
eu-länder 1 zumindest rumänien nutzt das
system gepard noch von daher alles das
was die kampffähigkeit erhält
unterstützt anzahl abwehr waffen
munition
gepanzerte fahrzeuge wir reden da zum
beispiel auch über den marder all das
kann die ukraine gebrauchen und
dementsprechend müssen wir auch schauen
was wie wir die ukraine unterstützen
können das müssen wir noch mal aufleben
er sensburg also wenn wir im panzer
schicken ohne zu wissen ob vergnügen
munition haben könnte es ja vor ort
durchaus ein problem werden ja das ist
absolut ein problem da ist zeit
vergeudet worden zwei monate lang fragt
die ukraine schon fast an und braucht
eben entsprechende waffensysteme wir
haben jetzt den beschluss gefasst dass
das waffensystem gepard geliefert wird
gepaart gehen wir hier in deutschland
noch haben jetzt müssen wir schauen dass
wir auch in ausreichender zahl munition
bekommen ich bin sehr zuversichtlich
dass wir hier noch munition erhalten
können was kann jetzt der gepard wie er
weit reicht überhaupt die abwehr bis in
den himmel herein also kann er überhaupt
das treffende vor denen die ukraine sich
zu fürchten haben also ich glaube ja wir
reden von ca 15 kilometern die der
gepard erreicht und gerade eben auch
gepanzerte hubschrauber flugzeuge aber
auch drohnen kann der gepard bekämpfen
effektiv bekämpfen er hat allen das
haben wir eben in dem bericht gesehen
ein radarsystem ein optisches system er
ist technisch einwandfrei ausgerüstet
dann für die luftabwehr ein aus meiner
sicht modernes system es ist nicht
unbrauchbar oder veraltet von daher ist
leistungsfähig er ist schnell beweglich
und ich glaube dass er die ukraine
gerade im bereich der bekämpfung der
ukraine der russischen luftwaffe
flugzeuge hubschrauber drohnen auch sehr
stark unterstützen kann herzlichen dank
an patrick sensburg
bundestagsabgeordneter für die union
bisher und jetzt eben chef des
reservistenverbandes danke für ihre
einschätzung